yes they did talk to pegida but the afd
insists it's the media that's trying to
place them into the right wing corner
some 2000 members gathered in bremen
they're convinced they are the only ones
talking straight
i wouldn't say the afd is right wing but
it is tackling long ignored issues that
must be addressed
at its party conference the afd is
mainly struggling with itself party
chief band looker is struggling to keep
a lid on his critics at the same time
the latest poll suggests that the public
perception is that the afd has shifted
to the right
entrepreneurs from within the party
disagree they say it's all about
business
there's no prosperity without a strong
middle class that's the afd position and
it's a cornerstone of our policies
the euro crisis is still at the top of
the afd's agenda now the party youth is
defining political territory
we believe that women have achieved
equality in germany
therefore we oppose any further
entitlements for women
it would run the risk of discriminating
against men
he's the winner the present co-party
leader luca will most likely take full
control at the top if he can unite his
party in two weeks time the city-state
of hamburg is going to the polls that
will be a litmus test on whether the
party has managed to reach the political
center in germany
which is exactly where it says it
already is